(upbeat music)
- [Drock] Yeah, I got that.
- You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
So we're at the VaynerSports,
Super Bowl basketball game.
We shoot around, we
can't get our athletes,
Jonny Toth, we can't
let this man get hurt.
So, they can just shoot around
but we're gonna play, for real.
(upbeat music)
- We have the dark clouds,
with the polo socks
just you know, ideal elbow jumper get-up.
So AJ knows, AJ knows
you're gonna drive the lane.
See me at the elbow and
I'm a bury the biscuit.
It's been a good weekend,
last night was good.
Thursday meet and greet,
that's Mr. Justin Giangrande,
he feels exponentially
cooler based on the outcome
of last night, which he deserves.
- [DRock] We got a good interview.
- [Tyler] We got a good interview?
- [Drock] (background
sounds drowns out speaker)
- [Tyler] Oh, Justin Giangradne?
- [Drock] Yeah.
- Justin G. Likes cut-off shirts,
'cause he's a cut-off shirt guy.
I was never really a cut-off shirt guy.
He's also mic-ed up for
Entrepreneur Magazine.
My man Carlos Gil, Matty Demayo,
he's getting buckets in a cardigan.
Cardigan never hurt nobody, looks like
he's actually got flannel-lined jeans on.
That's a good look by him.
- [Player] Hey people wanna run.
I'm just saying, People wanna run.
(basketballs thudding and shoes squeaking)
- You got that Drock?
- (laughing) Yeah I got that.
(upbeat music)
- Come on JT, come on!
- It's a great way to
work off the (laughs)
I'm not used to this.
It's a great way to work off last night,
that's the main thing,
it's nice to break a sweat.
And, I'm a great shooter,
can't do much else.
That's my single athletic ability.
I can shoot.
(upbeat music)
(laughter)
(music drowns out AJV)
- We needed that fucking bad.
- [Drock] Whoa, you almost killed him.
You almost killed him!
- We're hooping, this is the AM Hoops
Super bowl pop-up edition over here.
We're about to shoot some horse,
we started this tradition
last year in Minnesota.
AJ was the king last
year seeing if we can,
oh he's calling it, he's calling his shot.
- I just, fucking ran
horse for twelve seconds.
- Apparently AJ has already
claimed the throne but
we're gonna hoop, we got
all our clients out here,
VanyerSports, ten of the guys gonna
play some games and just
kinda unwind a little bit.
Super Bowl week can get super hectic,
good way to kinda get a
stretch and just reset.
(upbeat music)
(music drowns out voices)
- Hey we met briefly last night,
Joe Pasquarelli.
- I know who you are, yeah
- How you doing?
- good see you man,
good to see you again.
- You too.
Literally the two days before I met Mike,
I had 30 tabs open on my
Firefox of you and rappers
and I was trying to figure
out what was going on.
I was like how did this
dude have Gunna on a podcast
like six months before
anyone knew who Gunna was.
And then literally two days later
I was at Tree Sounds and
I met Micah he was like,
oh yeah I work with Gary.
- And you were like,
- And I was like now it all
makes sense.
- but you know what?
It's an important story
'cause you know we've
actually been doing a
version of it since 2009?
- Which is amazing.
- Yeah.
- It's not like, you know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's not something new
- No it's not new, I know and--
- That's why it works.
- And like being there last night,
it's just like how much
everyone fucks with you.
It's just like, it's an amazing thing.
- Last night so many of the players
were like wait, these guys know you?
I was like no no, they're
my friend friend friend.
(relaxing music)
(laughing)
- This is like watching The Office.
- 'Cause we never look around
anymore, it's like actors.
This is really good, this is better
than I thought it would be.
- [AJV] Me too.
- [Gary] You agree?
- So good.
- [AJV] Yeah.
- Yeah, it's also cool,
you're talking about it
like a show at this point.
- Yeah.
- It was so overly obvious
first couple.
- [AJV] Right.
- [Tyler] So it's, it's new.
- It's more the office.
- [Tyler] It's like, yeah.
- [AJV] It's very office like.
- We gotta bring that back.
(video plays)
- One thing I underestimated
is what it's gonna
be feeling like to watch old daily vee's.
- I gotta put a shirt on
with all this content.
All this content being captured
I'm fucking buck naked and out of shape.
- Tyler what's your favorite
episode of daily video?
- The day we moved the offices from 305.
- Do you know how (muffled)
that is, hold on, hold on.
- [Tyler] I don't know what number it is,
it's in the three's I believe.
(video playing)
- That's fucking cool, oh my God go back!
Oh my God, this is incredible, ready?
- [AJV] Is it the Super Bowl?
- Nope, go back to the, look
at this, look at the cab.
- Purewow?
- [Tyler] Purewow!
Wow, that was before the acquisition.
- That's really cool.
- [Tyler] That's cool
- Like you knew Harwood at this point.
- Yeah but it's still cool.
- I think overrated.
(laughing)
You're pretending that you
didn't know who Harwood was.
- No but I mean. (video plays)
- [AJV] What is this right now?
- (Gary on video) two or
three guys that can actually
execute, Bezos is the next new Jobs.
I promise watch the--
- [AJV] What year is this?
- 2011.
- [AJV] That's good.
- Thank you, let's go.
- [AJV] How much stock did you buy?
- Not enough.
But I bought some.
- [AJV] Me neither.
- Whatever this says we'll (mumbles).
Tomorrow your creative side will
shine forth with exceptional ideas.
(yelling)
That's crazy.
- You have to go dark.
- (mumbling), tomorrow your creative side
will shine forth with exceptional ideas.
That means I go dark?
- That's how I read it.
- Really? I read it as triple
down on putting on us on tap.
- I thought it was
hunker down in the room,
come up with bad ideas and then do them.
- [AJV] Yeah well, go dark.
- Right, let's go, let's
go, turn it around.
(video plays)
Bogus.
- Font's face in this thing is so good.
- [AJV] Yeah, I need a shot.
- Shout out 50.
(rap music plays from video)
That's fucking fresh man.
- Yeah so fresh.
(upbeat music)